foreign
here we are ladies and gentlemen it's
Monday night and we're talking about
a horror movie sorry I was checking to
see make sure that the microphone I'm
making sure the damn because we keep
moving [__] around moving [__] around
what is up with this I don't know okay
yeah it's it's uh it's even I guess yeah
this [__] house man
of all those [__] with the lighting
and [__] yeah he's been [__] with the
lighting so it's like we're moving stuff
around everywhere you know how we do
it's not it's never consistent from day
to day yeah but what are you gonna do
what are we gonna do
so yeah
um I just happened to watch this movie
did we watch it last night or the night
no I guess it wasn't last night I guess
it was the night before
um and I had actually been curious to
see this I'm not usually I'm usually
kind of ambivalent about horror remakes
especially if it's a remake of something
that's kind of a classic but I was kind
of curious to see this one and I saw
that it was on I think it was on uh if
you go on Amazon Prime and sometimes
it'll have those movies that are like
freebie and you can watch them with ads
and they are free and so I saw that this
one in there and I was like ah might as
well I'm gonna just pull the trigger on
it and I will say that it got pretty
mixed reviews at the time but this was
actually much better than I was
expecting I thought it was pretty good
much better than I was expecting it's um
it's similar enough to the original like
the the bones of the story are the same
but they did a little bit something
different with it to kind of justify
making a remake I guess I mean the thing
about it is that rabid we've covered the
original rabbit from 1977.
um you know the David Cronenberg film
and you know it's one of his early films
I feel like
um I don't like it as much as like The
Brood you know what I mean
um but it's still pretty good and
so it's so it's not like you're taking
something like video drone and remaking
it or you're just kind of taking one of
his Classics but not his best one you
know what I mean like his older one and
kind of updating it so I didn't mind it
as much although I think as far as I
know this might be has anybody else
remade a David Cronenberg movie
or is this the first one I don't know
it's like I can't really I know David
Cronenberg did a remake he did the fly
um but I can't think of anybody remaking
a David carnenberg movie it's just
offhand I mean I feel like there's got
to be ones other than this but he's just
such a singular filmmaker that I kind of
feel like most people wouldn't have the
audacity I guess because his vision is
so distinctive but [__] if somebody
remade Suspiria I guess somebody can
remake this too
but yeah so this came out in 2019 was
directed by uh the saska sisters uh Jen
and Sylvia who are twins they're
Canadian and um probably they've made
several movies but um they're probably
their best known one is American Mary uh
which was actually quite good
it's about extreme body modification so
it was like super gory this one is not
as gory as that one but it was still
pretty gory
so like the original movie because if
you've seen the original movie it had
Marilyn Chambers you know the porn star
this was like her first uh like
mainstream role yeah and she actually
did a good job in this
um but this one I like that they stuck
with the Canadian like most of the
actors are Canadian most of it they shot
it in Canada although they didn't it
doesn't have that super Canada e kind of
thing that David kronenberg [__] usually
has it does feel like a Cronenberg movie
though it does it did kind of they
totally did
yeah
um I did
I did notice and it was funny because I
was watching a couple of other um
reviews of this and I think some of the
younger reviewers because there's a
scene in this that very obviously I mean
very obviously homage's dead ringers uh
the 1988 David kronenberg movie like
with the red surgical scrubs
um and you know they even like kind of
reenacted the scene a little bit like
with the way that the the actor removed
the ceremony right right right and it's
and so a couple of um like one of the
reviewers I saw he looked like he was in
his 20s or something like that he liked
the movie but he was just like he didn't
understand he was like what was that
random [__] all about random it's
somebody in the comment said bro that's
like that was from dead ringers so I
think they also among Shivers in there
too if I was because there was a couple
things in there that I was like oh I see
what you did there you know what I mean
so you could tell that the Sasuke
sisters were really I mean they're big
horror fans they're big Cronenberg fans
and they made this respectfully you know
I mean I think it was good I think it
was a good I yeah I actually quite liked
it yeah I think it can stand where the
Cronenberg flick I think it's better
than the original in the in in terms of
like being updated
because you know the original rabbit is
kind of crude by today's standards yeah
it was very low budget it was one of his
earlier movies you know so he didn't
have a lot of money to work with he
played this alongside you know video
drove and
and some of the newer Cronenberg movies
that came out like the one that came out
with all the weird body [__] horror
[__] what was the one we saw the theater
oh um uh oh [__] now I can't remember
what it was called yeah where they were
growing weird internal organs yeah yeah
yeah Crimes of the future Crimes of the
future yes it's like you know not quite
as odd as that but
yeah it kind of felt like a like a
modern Cronenberg movie yeah in a way
yeah
um yeah but I mean they do have their
own distinctive style too but like I
said I like the kind of little homages
they put on there not just the dead
ringers one which was like screamingly
obvious because that's probably I don't
know if I'd say that's my favorite
Cronenberg movie but I really that's the
one I've seen the most times I like it a
lot
um but I like that some of the shots
they did even though it's set in the
present day it seems like they did try
to Homage the look of the 1970s like
they'd go in places and it was like that
cheesy paneling and [__] like that so I
kind of like that they that they did
that you know what I'm saying yeah so
if you haven't seen the original rabid
um it's basically like it's not like
it's not zombies but it's you know it's
rabies it's a it's like a viral outbreak
type of movie but weirder than that so
in the original movie
uh the character of Rose who's played by
Marilyn Chambers
um she gets in a motorcycle accident and
gets kind of and it's near this like
weird experimental clinic or whatever
and they pick her up and take her there
and do start doing like experimental
skin grafts on her like without her
consent really
um and as sometimes happens she
um grows like a mouth in her armpit that
is kind of like a vampirey type thing
where she kind of goes and like you know
stabs people with it and then like
drinks their blood but then it's like
rabies so it passes from person to
person and then like the whole thing
kind of goes through and like she
doesn't realize that she's essentially
like patient zero you know what I mean
because she isn't affected by it because
she's kind of like the disease Vector
yeah they kind of make it a little more
plausible
too because they start getting into
things like Gene gene therapy and
that's how it was done through genetic
science
yeah and one thing that I thought was an
interesting choice and maybe this is
because I'm not entirely sure if this is
maybe just because this was um
female filmmakers
um the character of Rose in the remake
has a lot more personal agency
because in the original she's in the
motorcycle wreck she's unconscious and
they just basically just scoop her up
and throw her in the clinic and start
doing [__] to her like while she's
unconscious you know what I mean in this
one
um even though the kind of the events
are the same she actually chooses a lot
of the things like she so she's in this
motorcycle accident which actually it's
not her fault necessarily but it's
because she's jumps on her motorcycle
she's not really looking so it's kind of
her fault a little bit but then like
after she's in the motorcycle action
accident she actually gets taken to a
regular hospital but her face is all
[__] up and the special effects I
think are all practical and they look
really really good like especially when
her when they take the bandages off her
face and she's all like her mouth is all
[__] up and everything
so she ends up like after they release
her from the hospital she finds out
about this transhumanism Clinic
um that's called the Burroughs Clinic
which I think was in homage to William
Burroughs I'm assuming
um so she makes the choice to go there
you know what I mean so it's not like
she just got dumped in there without
knowing about it she actually does go
there and say yeah you can do the [__]
on me
um you know because they're gonna do the
stuff on her for free and it actually
takes a lot longer
it's kind of a slower build I feel like
I haven't seen the original in a while
but I feel like the in the original it's
just kind of like you know they go in
they give her the skin grafts or
whatever and then you pretty much see
the armpit [__] like not not too far
into it and then she just starts going
around like seducing men and like
sucking their blood or whatever in this
one it's a lot more there's a lot more
that happens like there's a lot more
character development that happens like
before the motorcycle accident so
there's that because she's the the
character of Rose here that kind of
portrays like this Dowdy uh you know
just very shy insecure kind of woman she
works for a fashion house with this like
stereotypical German Artie farty like
fashion designer douche
um and she wants to be a fashion
designer but she's not like confident so
it's it's kind of the classic because
she's obviously like a beautiful woman
but they slap glasses on her put like a
frumpy sweater on and they're just like
yeah she's a total Wallflower and I'm
like okay so then like after they do the
um
so there's a lot of that kind of [__]
but then after they do the um the
surgery on her she actually like is
completely healed and actually like
looks better even like fixes her vision
and all this other kind of [__] because
they do all this gene therapy and they
kind of build up for a while that
because she was a vegetarian before and
then they give her these bottles of
protein drinks which I'm like that's
probably blood because you know that the
dude that's running the clinic is
totally
into this he knows what's going on so
it's like yeah you just have to drink
these protein shakes and then she starts
having like cravings for raw meat and
then she just starts having these things
where she you know goes out much like in
the original movie and just sees a dude
and like kind of loses it and and kind
of eats them a little bit you know just
kind of bites his neck or whatever they
actually don't even show the armpit
thing until probably about three
quarters of the way through and I think
like in the original movie because like
I said the original movie was pretty low
budget I think it was just it was just
like a slit and like a stinger kinda
like if I remember correctly in this one
it's a full-on tentacle but you know
that comes like way out but you don't
really see it all that much until the
end but yeah I mean like I said I'm not
I'm ambivalent about remakes but I was
kind of curious to see this one because
I had liked American Mary which is the
only other Sasuke Sisters movie that
I've seen
um they get a lot of [__] for whatever
reason I don't really know why
but
um but honestly if you're gonna if
you're gonna remake A Cronenberg movie
uh I think this was a really good
attempt like I said it's similar enough
to the original and as homages to the
original but they changed the story up
enough to kind of put their own spin on
it you know what I mean which is really
all you can do they didn't try to
slavishly remake it they didn't try to
make it exactly like a Cronenberg movie
you know they put their own style on it
also I laughed because the um Jen and
Sylvia saska also were cameos in this as
these kind of coke snorting [__] like
at this party like they were they were
talking about the main character like
what a sad pathetic [__] she was so uh
so I thought that was very funny that
they put themselves in there I don't
know if that's something that they do
all the time
but but yeah I mean I thought it was
pretty good yeah I mean I thought it was
pretty good too yeah
um the ending was kind was actually kind
of it was a lot different than the
original like a spoiler alert if you
haven't seen the original one from 1977
um basically Rose Dies at the End of the
original one and the the thing about it
that's that makes the ends kind of
devastating is that they don't know that
she was patient zero that she was the
one that started it and she basically
just gets hauled out of her apartment
like thrown in a garbage truck or
something like that like along with the
other bodies like they don't know that
she was the one that started it
um which you know was kind of which was
kind of a depressing ending but it was
kind of a cool ending too this one
I don't necessarily want to spoil the
ending but this one takes like a a far
different attack because I think that in
the original if I remember correctly and
if anybody has seen it more recently
than I have maybe you can like remind me
but I thought in the original that yeah
they were doing weird [__] with uh with
genetics and all that other kind of
stuff at the clinic the keloid clinic
but the the mouth in the armpit that was
like an unintentional side effect of the
skin grafts I don't think they actually
meant to do that
whereas in this
um it seems like the clinic is a lot
more Sinister in their intentions you
know what I mean like they are actually
trying to or like the guy that's running
it is actually trying to like I don't
think he was necessarily trying to cause
a rabies outbreak but I mean he was
definitely trying to do something along
those lines so he so it wasn't like oh
my God we messed up this thing and you
know all hell broke loose he was just
kind of like oh interesting you know
what I mean so I think he was kind of
had more nefarious intentions you know
um Faded Line said this one is a remake
yes it is
um as I mentioned yeah this is a remake
of a David kronenberg movie from 1977
and um not pretty good I mean it was
pretty good like I said I think on
Rotten Tomatoes I think I saw it had
like 56 like so that's kind of mixed
reviews and when I saw like I I read and
like looked at several different reviews
and it seemed to like there was a couple
horror reviewers that I liked that
really did not like it
um I don't really know why it didn't
seem that
offensive or you know what I mean
um but then some people most people
thought it was like yeah it was pretty
good
um you know depending on if you saw the
original I don't know I'm still gonna
give it to the original because it's
Cronenberg and he has his own thing
going on but honestly if you're gonna
remake it and update it for 2019 you
could have done a lot worse and I don't
know I I pretty much dug it I thought it
was like pretty cool and I actually even
liked the ending even though it's a lot
different than the original because I do
like the original ending too but yeah so
if you have anything else you'd like to
add about it this is like the shortest
review ever yeah
now what do you want to talk about
what do you want to talk about now
because everything some people just got
here yeah how long have you been how
long we've been on we've only been on
for 20 minutes okay we've only been on
for 20 minutes
so yeah what are we gonna do nothing you
can just end it
I had all I could say about it you know
what I mean it was just it was just a
flake it was cool flick yeah yeah I mean
I actually liked it I quite liked it did
make you mad or anything
that sounds great yeah for like [__]
like that but yeah um so I feel bad that
it like didn't take that long to like
talk about this movie that's how it is
but you know what I mean yep um but yeah
it's Monday night
tomorrow is my birthday I'm turning 51
tomorrow yep
uh you know
going to going to Disney yep you go
tomorrow going to Disney for the
Halloween thing and then Wednesday I'm
going to Epcot so if you guys weren't
here I mentioned on Friday that the
Regular Show this week which is actually
going to be about Creepy internet
Mysteries
that's gonna be we're gonna move it to
Thursday night because I'm actually not
entirely sure like what time I'm gonna
be getting back home on Wednesday and it
probably won't be in time to do the show
at the regular time and I'll probably be
worn out so we were going to push the
Regular Show back to Thursday night at 7
30.
Eastern Standard Time should be back
Wednesday evening yeah yeah okay because
I'm like I said I don't I'm going with
my siblings and I'm not really sure how
late they're going to want to stay like
because I think epcot's open until nine
so I don't know if we're gonna stay
there until then or if we're gonna get
worn out before then I don't I don't
really know what's gonna happen but
it'll be so don't start getting worried
unless I'm not back before like 10 or 11
at night but yeah yeah I'm gonna have my
phone and stuff like that
um okay so a couple people ask some
questions uh Camp guys that I believe
the most common carriers of rabies are
raccoons and bats yeah I've heard that
as well
um let's see
um
Tammy says I wanted to wish you a happy
birthday early and hope you have fun at
Disney thank you very much I'm planning
to I think it'll be fun like I said we
me and my sister went to the Halloween
event last year and it was like super
fun so we're doing the same one again
and I haven't been to Epcot in forever
so it'll be nice to go see it and let's
see uh Jenny and Tom are you guys ever
gonna do a retrospective of sleep away
camp honestly I thought we had already
done it but I first I don't know why but
I was thinking about it the other day oh
I think because I saw it when I was
scrolling through the movies I don't
think I've ever seen it and I was like
[__] I don't think we've ever seen we've
ever done I've seen it a couple of times
but um I don't remember ever doing uh I
don't think I've ever seen it
you might like it it's like it's from
the 80s it's kind of like a like a camp
slasher but with a Twist I guess okay I
don't wanna oh yeah yeah you know what
I'm talking about like I said if you
haven't seen it I don't want to spoil
the ending for you even though as soon
as you started watching it you would
probably remember like because the the
images at the end is like super iconic
that's one of like the most iconic
endings like in all of Horror
like especially that
that one shot of that character you know
what I mean I'm trying to like I know I
know people probably know what it is but
I'm trying to like dance around it you
know what I mean Tammy says Gonna Miss
Thursday might be able to sneak in to
say hi but Eddie Izard starts at 8pm oh
that's right yeah that's on the Thursday
night so yeah you're not gonna be able
to make it well You're Gonna Be Seeing
Eddie Izzard oh Danny really ghost face
is back yeah where have you been yeah we
tried to answer your message a long time
ago
um you weren't blocked from this channel
there's a lot of people that can't post
for some reason we don't know what it is
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's right time
ago he's like I can't I could he
couldn't see that he couldn't Post in
the live stream yeah you're not the only
one and I'm not yeah and I'm not really
sure like nobody nobody is blocked yeah
nobody nobody has blocked I I went and
looked and there's not a single blind
person like in my in my [__] yeah my
understanding is is that uh uh AI
if you've been
AI doesn't like the [__] you've been
saying on other programs they can
[__] silence you in in live stream
that may be what it is is that Thunder
yeah holy [__] yeah
Danny Rowling says Thomas should totally
see Book of Shadows Blair Witch 2 just
saying you know I haven't seen it in a
while but I just from what I remember I
would go to bat for Blair Witch too I
know it gets [__] on a lot like people
saying it's like a terrible Sequel and
stuff like that I remember quite liking
it I like that they did something they
didn't do found footage they kind of
like went a little bit meta with it and
like I said I'd be curious to see it
again because it's probably been 15
years at least since I've seen it but I
remember enjoying it and being like not
really understanding all the all the
hate that it gets so I don't know I
might watch it again and be like oh no I
get it I don't know because I was like a
different person back then
but I remembered like kind of liking it
like I said I like that they went meta
John Gora said I liked the burning
better Sleepaway Camp does have a freaky
finale yeah the burning is good too
um that was one I remember seeing that
one a lot because Tom savini worked on
it and uh you know I had all those like
documentaries about Tom savini and they
always had shots from that
but wasn't that the burning was the one
that had all the later famous people in
it wasn't it like Holly Hunter and Jason
Alexander and stuff like that was it
that's what I'm thinking of right
that's yeah I think that's what I'm
thinking of but yeah it was one of those
old slashers that had like people that
became massively famous later on in like
their first roles
um let's see
Camp guy said believe it or not one of
the most dangerous things outdoors and
camping is falling trees
lots of folks get killed by trees you
know what's weird that reminded me it's
like when I was in Wales
they told me that right down the street
from where I was living there had been
this car full of people just driving by
and uh just freakily there wasn't a
storm or anything like this tree just
fell and it fell in their car and killed
all of them damn and I was just like
can you imagine just like [__]
I guess you gotta eat Something's Gonna
Get Serious it really does it's getting
really really cool we got the window
it's getting really really loud really
loud
yeah American Military 100 said the
burning is awesome yeah it's really good
uh yes Holly Hunter oh yeah Fisher
Stevens is in it too I forgot all about
that and wasn't Jason Alexander in it I
want to say Jason Alexander
but holy crap
holy crap cats and dogs out yeah I don't
know if you can hear that but holy [__]
it just went yeah
this guy just exploded like in Florida
man it's crazy Florida man good all
right so
you seem not to want to talk
about it okay
so I guess we're gonna wreck yeah she
can blame it on me well I should say it
it's like sometimes sometimes you
already talk about something and then we
can like start talking about something
but you don't seem to like want to talk
about anything that's the topic you know
that's that's true like I said you go
off and it's not really into this topic
that much I mean it's okay
all right well you can talk about other
[__] if you want yeah that's off topic
okay well we already talked about the
movie though yeah we talked about the
movie so it's okay all right so I guess
we're gonna wrap it up uh and then
remember we're not gonna be back until
Thursday night to try not to miss us too
badly so I'm gonna be doing birthday
[__] tomorrow and Wednesday so hopefully
that'll be fine hopefully the weather's
not like this tomorrow that would suck I
don't want to have to drive in it but
yeah so uh we'll see you guys again on
Thursday night and thank you for
dropping by this evening and we'll see
you then bye